Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. You know, I've said
it many times before. Criticized me for things. I
said, if you don't like them, if I got it wrong.
But don't criticize me for things I haven't talked
about. Here is a caller who is furious with what I
said about Manosphere darling Andrew Tate. Except
I don't know what this guy's talking about. I
didn't ever say any of this stuff. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: David. Live or Pacman. What are you.
If I could play for you.
Speaker 1: Milo Kuklinski,
What does that even mean?
Speaker 6: Yeah, I come out
and apologize for fear, for for coming to the
conclusion that Andrew Case automatically guilty
after being arrested. I find it funny that you
guys, I never talk about white faces pretty
much at all. And then all of a sudden when he
gets arrested, you guys, you guys made videos
about him? What? What getting arrested. One of
the videos coming out talking about how he was
released and why did you guys apologize?
Speaker 1: And apologize for what?
Speaker 6: In what you said, you guys were all
convinced that he was pretty much guilty by all
accounts of human trafficking and whatnot.
And now he's been let go after four months.
It's crazy to think that once upon a
time, the liberals were for or against
the government and all of their shenanigans. Now
it's across the board. And now you guys are for
government. Everything you ever done questioning,
questioning anything government related. Dude.
Speaker 1: I don't know what the hell you're
talking about, so. Milo Kuklinski I don't know
what that's about as far as I'm concerned. There
are two claims made about me. One that when Andrew
Tate was arrested, I said he's pretty much guilty.
And two, that I had never spoken about Andrew Tate
prior to that. Both statements are false. First
and foremost, I've spoken about Andrew Tate in a
segment about the manosphere in which I talked
also about Liver King and Jordan Peterson. So
I have spoken about Andrew Tate once before.
Secondly, I haven't weighed in at all about
the Andrew Tate arrest. And in fact, during a
livestream, someone said, David, what do you think
about Andrew Tate being arrested? And I said, I
don't think anything I don't have anything to say.
It's just it's not really a topic on this show.
I don't know. He's accused of crimes. I don't
know. I just I just have no idea. So, listen, I'm
glad to defend the things I've said on this show,
and I'm glad to correct things I've said on this
show if they are wrong. But don't call me about
things I haven't said. Call someone who's actually
said it, but you're wasting everybody's time. We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today. Florida
has expanded its don't say gay rules to include
up to and including 12th grade. And this is part
of why Republican mega-donors are not happy with
Ron DeSantis. We'll talk about it on the bonus
show. Secondly, there are more calls for schools
to drop Native American mascots, and some schools
could end up losing state money over this. Very
interesting what's going on. And lastly, we now
have two shootings that have taken place stemming
from a mistaken address. And this is putting the
spotlight back on Stand Your Ground laws the way
we really haven't seen since Stand your Ground
laws were at the heart of the George Zimmerman
Trayvon Martin killing years and years ago. So
we're going to talk about Stand your Ground when
producer Pat joins me on the bonus show.
Speaker 4: O the bonus show where you
want to make money, search.
Speaker 5: Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: That's exactly right. We're going
to be making some money on the bonus show. You
can sign up at join Pacman dot com. You can get
instant access to the bonus, show the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show. The
members only soundboard.
Speaker 6: Oh bum.
Speaker 1: Now as well as getting invited
to the member only town halls the next of
which will be announced very soon. Sign up
at join Packman dot com. Use the coupon code
indicted or indicated. Both work both.
Get you a discount. I'll see you then.